even in death daenerys targaryen remains
something of an enigma the assassination
of Amelia clerks icy haired aspiring
queen of dragons on HBO's Game of
Thrones was a particularly shocking
moment on a series filled with them on
the off chance that you need a refresher
here's a bit of background after
Daenerys went mad and torched the
capital city of King's Landing she
finally reached the Iron Throne but
Daenerys never actually took her place
as the ruler of Westeros before she
could even so much as take a seat her
nephew / lover Jon Snow played by kit
harington assassinated her for the good
of the realm it was a choice that led to
his banishment back to the Nights Watch
bringing Jon's story full circle
following Daenerys as death her grieving
dragon drogon wasted no time torching
the Iron Throne to the ground then the
fiery creature scooped up Danny's body
and flew off to an unknown location
since the final game of Thrones episode
aired many fans have wondered what
exactly happened to Daenerys his body
after she was killed
where did drogon take her and what did
he subsequently do to her now these
mysteries have been somewhat solved
thanks to the commentary track on the
DVD release of the show's final season
according to Entertainment Weekly
showrunner his DB Weiss and David
Benioff have finally revealed what Rogen
did with Daenerys his body or at the
very least one big thing he didn't do
with it they finally debunked the
disturbing theory that drogon actively
ate his mother and master you wouldn't
do that would you dro Khan
in the commentary track Emilia Clarke
notes that she would have expected
drogon to simply eat the body of his
former master
- which Benioff replied drogon is not
going to eat you he's not a cat
did you see how gently he was nudging
you so that's good to know
drogon didn't just fly away with
Daenerys his body and dumped it
somewhere nor did he ravenously devour
the remains of his human mother at the
end of the series finale
samwell tarly played by john bradley
notes where drogon was last seen in
drogon any word he was less spotted
flying east - either way the better he's
cut off but not before revealing a huge
clue
it sounds like drogon took Danny to
volantis which is where Daenerys and her
brother Viserys spend some time
following the assassination of their
father during Robert's rebellion Benioff
took on another theory about drogon but
he provides far less closure here we may
never know exactly why drogon destroyed
the throne after Daenerys died but
Benioff did hint at his intention in
relation to Danny's own desires saying
if Jani is not going to sit on it no
one's going to sit on it
when discussing anything even
peripherally related to Daenerys as
death including what happened to her
body afterwards one must inevitably
speak the name of the man who performed
the deed Jon Snow Daenerys is fiery
rampage through the streets of King's
Landing left countless civilians dead
and it became abundantly clear that her
ruthlessness knew no bounds a fact that
left John with a difficult decision to
make after Peter Dinklage's Tyrion
Lannister quits his post as Daenerys as
hand of the Queen and protests John
visits him in captivity and the two have
a serious talk about John's next steps
will he turn the other cheek to Dany
shocking crimes and choose to love her
even though she's clearly drunk with
power or will he kill her thus ending
the chaos and destruction she brought to
Westeros we all know John ultimately
chose the latter stabbing Daenerys in
the chest as the two embraced and
according to the game of thrones DVD
commentary John didn't know he was going
to do the dreadful deed until seconds
before it happened it wasn't his talk
with Tyrion that convinced him to make
that grave decision it was hearing
Danny's warped views on power and
privilege that ultimately made him kill
her as harrington puts it he doesn't
know he's going to betray
her until right at the end in John's
head it's a number of reasons Danny
doesn't factor in anyone else's
decisions and it also means Danny is
going to kill my sister's so it becomes
my family versus her well Danny may be
dead but at least she didn't become
Dragon Chow and it sounds like Emilia
Clarke has her own theories about what
ultimately became of drogon and Danny's
corpse judging by what she told Vanity
Fair in November 2019 she's just roaming
the seas crying you think he's somewhere
happy flying with the corpse in his
mouth yeah cuz it's his MoMA check out
one of our newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos about your
favorite movies and TV shows are coming
soon subscribe to our YouTube channel
and hit the bell so you don't miss a
single one
[Music]